elle range une partie de la ville devant
couvert depuis des années la
consommation de drogue est plus que
jamais une crise de santé publique
on s'approvisionne de façon plus
dangereuse dit-elle parce que les
policiers confisquent tout ce que les
toxicomanes ont sur eux mais cette
époque est révolue à partir
d'aujourd'hui la Colombie-Britannique
décriminalise la possession de petites
quantités de drogues détenir deux
grammes et demi et moins de cocaïne de
méthamphétamines ou d'opioïdes ne sera
plus une infraction criminelle
c'est une avancée historique affirme la
coronaire en chef depuis 2016 la
Colombie-Britannique compte plus de
11000 décès liés aux opioïdes près de
2300 personnes sont mortes en 2022
seulement
il faut aller de l'avant les expériences
santé publique indépendance avec ce
genre de mesure là sinon ça serait
encore pire selon lui la
décriminalisation de la possession de
drogue encourage les utilisateurs à
demander de l'aide le train de la
réforme des politiques d'encadrement des
drogues au Canada en Occident est en
marche ça va ça va continuer et je pense
et j'ose espérer qu'on va aller vers un
modèle encadré par l'État qui offre des
produits plus sûrs malgré tout les
autres provinces pour l'instant ferment
la porte la porte est toujours fermée on
travaille en collaboration avec les
différents organismes de sur une
personne qui ont des enjeux de
toxicomanie mais l'un de ces organismes
justement cactus Montréal demande à
Québec d'en faire plus les surdoses font
en moyenne 450 victimes par année dans
la province depuis 2018 j'aimerais que
le ministre de la Justice et le courage
de dire à ce moment-là que cette
initiative là n'est pas pertinent faut
savoir qu'au Québec actuellement il y a
plus de morts par sur deux que de mort
sur la route
comment est-ce qu'on ne peut pas être
ouvert à des initiatives qui peuvent
permettre de sauver des vies donc la
façon la plus sécuritaire de monter
pipacrac ici on veut que ceux qui
consomment le fasse de façon sécuritaire
mais le meilleur moyen d'y arriver et de
s'attaquer à l'approvisionnement on
pourrait faire le parallèle avec de
l'eau contaminée si la population
n'avait seulement accès qu'à de l'eau
contaminée on remplacerait cette
contaminé là par de l'eau potable il
faut dit-il des drogues sans fantanyiles
ou autres poisons pour freiner cette
épidémie une bonne fois pour toute ici
Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada
Montréal